former Project Runway hair stylist  George Ortiz has died Ortiz's sister  confirmed to ET that George took his own  life on Tuesday at his apartment in New  York City he was 45 years old she shared  the heartbreaking news in a statement  then reads it's a tragic loss for our  family it is so surreal to know that he  is no longer with us and sharing his  infectious smile I have comfort in  knowing that he was loved by so many  people both in the industry and not he  will forever be missed  George appeared on the reality  competition series from 2006 to 2010 as  a key hair stylist and he had a notable  career working for celebs including  Glenn Close